do you want to use me why yes we do  smells heinous oh it's a little tangy  bitter it's almost like it has defense  mechanism for you not to eat it coz it  tastes so bad a prickly pear that's food  mmm never food is like it's pretty good  it's like a bell pepper it's slimy  not some chunks in there yeah now this  this is appropriate for ranch I assume  because it would be found on our ranch  you eat the stem too ah ooh this is  garbage right here theoretically you can  eat anything like anything is edible if  it's small enough right whoa  this is Purple Haze man Oh God  it doesn't taste good but what happens  if I blow a line of it I'm gonna I'm  just gonna go to town on this these guys  are cute that's exactly what I expect  from fine dining Daniel I'm sweet hey I  do feed this tomorrow of it I would eat  that that's good ha ha I don't know  pretty flavorful your rabbit likes this  yeah I mean he also eats his own poop